with only six episodes left in the
entire series the second episode of the
eighth and final season of Game of
Thrones had a lot of groundwork to lay
down as a show comes to an end from is
big moment to Brienne's new title let's
talk about the second episode of Game of
Thrones final season and what it all
means when Jaime Lannister turns up at
Winterfell to help in the fight against
the incoming army of the Dead he doesn't
exactly receive a warm welcome and it's
no wonder why not only is Jaime forced
to face down bran the boy he once tried
to murder when bran court Jaime sleeping
with his queen and sister but he also
has to come face to face of Daenerys
whose father he successfully murdered
despite being a member of the Kingsguard
and swearing to protect him meanwhile
Sansa Stark is still angry at Jaime for
turning on her own father Ned Stark
drawing their shared time in King's
Landing but in the end his friend and
Ally Brienne of Tarth stands up for the
Kingslayer
convincing Sansa to allow Jaime to stay
safely in Winterfell Jaime may still be
guilty of Plenty but it looks like
you'll live to fight another day
chances are good that the mercy shown by
both Sansa and Daenerys will have
lasting effects on the conflicts to come
as the series wraps up over the next few
episodes now that the two leaders have
found some common ground as possible
they'll find a way to work together to
unite the Seven Kingdoms then again
after realizing that Sansa needed to be
convinced to accept a new Queen Daenerys
sits down alone with the eldest stark
and Lady of Winterfell in the second
episode determined to win over the stoic
survivor and explain what she hopes to
accomplish at drawing her time in
Westeros the meeting seems to go well at
first
Sansa even cracks a smile and the two
join hands as they talk about Jon but it
all eventually goes south when Sansa
makes it clear that she doesn't want to
relinquish the North's claim for
independence once the narrowest takes
the Iron Throne leaving things just as
tense as they were before that chats
Daenerys says intentions might be good
but it's unlikely that she'll ever fully
impress anyone in the north making it
that much harder for her to unite
Westeros under her rule
Daenerys may think she has John's
loyalty are given how the other lords of
the North view Sansa may not end up
being enough to keep hold in the region
in the end on the eve of one of the most
frightening and difficult battles
throughout the entire run of Game of
Thrones the characters prepare for the
conflict to come during what might be
their very last night alive and
everybody deals with their in completely
different ways while some like Tyrion
and torment drink heavily
the single on the song and some achieve
goals they've worked towards for their
entire lives Brienne of Tarth in
particular has a banner night when Jamie
anoint sir as the first female Knight in
all of the Seven Kingdoms and one of the
final seasons most emotional moments to
date
aside from Brienne's new title audiences
are given acquired to get stood
incredibly tense episode and a build-up
to one of the series most ambitious
battles yet but a seemingly unbeatable
army of the Dead arrives to take
Winterfell even though some fans might
have been disappointed by the lack of
action the episode let viewers spend a
thoughtful and often funny hour with
some of their favorite characters some
of whom probably won't be around after
the next episodes enormous battle over
the course of seven seasons of viewers
have watched as aya stark has grown from
a small feisty tomboy to a fearless
faceless Warrior willing to mow down
anything in a path now that she has
finally returned home to Winterfell and
joined a family ire is truly in her
element during the eighth season
premiere she reunites with Gendry our
old friend working as a Smith in
Winterfell forge asking him to make a
new custom weapon a request which is as
close to aya will probably ever get to
flirting on the night before the battle
with the night king aya makes a somewhat
surprising decision visiting Gendry to
pick up a new spear and then seducing
him so that she can know what it's like
to be with a man before the day breaks
and the battle begins beside serving as
an incredible example of one of the
show's most powerful female characters
taking control of a sexuality and
exercising her autonomy it also calls
back to something that King Robert
Baratheon setting Game of Thrones very
first episode about joining houses with
Ned Stark between Ned's daughter and
Robert's son King Robert was referring
to Joffrey and Sansa
but since Gendry is actually Robert's
bastard son and ire is also Ned's
daughter it seems as if the late king's
prediction has come true after all this
time there's still plenty of secrets
left to be revealed on Game of Thrones
but one of the series biggest bombshells
specifically the one concerning Jon
Snow's real heritage was blown wide open
during the ape season premiere when Sam
broke the news to a stunt friend who had
to grapple with the fact that is the
actual rightful heir to the Iron Throne
not to mention that his new girlfriend
is actually as ants after spending his
life assuming that he was nothing more
than Ned Stark's bastard son Jon now has
to consider the very real possibility
that he could rule all of Westeros since
his parents Lyanna Stark
and rhaegar targaryen were rightfully
married making him a legitimate royal
obviously this creates plenty of
awkwardness between John and Daenerys
who only recently consummated their new
relationship but awkward family reunions
aside John breaking the news to the
Narus about his real name and potential
title throws another wrench into the
proceedings
Daenerys whose single goal throughout
the series has been to take the Iron
Throne
now has another rival to contend with
with whom she hasn't conveniently fallen
in love now that both characters know
that the humble supposedly lowborn Jon
Snow is actually Aegon Targaryen
Daenerys might turn on him entirely
setting up a huge conflict between two
of the show's most important characters
in terms of moments that will have
lasting effects through the final
episode of the series heed this
encounter and the Stark crypt fresh in
your mind
a conflict between John and Daenerys may
be on hold while they fight for the
survival of the human race but once a
night King melts into a puddle of goo
expect the full repercussions of this
conversation to become much more clear
in the light of day check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]